border patrol officials tell fox news
that a majority of asylum seekers at the
southern border are being returned to
mexico now that's after the supreme
court ordered last month that the trump
era policy be reinstated jonathan hunt
is live in la jolla texas for us where
you can catch us up hi jonathan
hi dana we're trying to get official
word from either the department of
homeland security homeland security or
the white house as to whether there has
been a formal order since that supreme
court ruling sent down to border patrol
agents but as you look at pictures of
families arriving here in la jolla early
sunday evening i can tell you that at
least one border patrol supervisor is
telling us that now
all families are being sent back unless
they have a child
under the age of one pregnant women are
being allowed to stay as well but that
is about it according to this border
patrol officials others are all being
sent back to mexico in the wake of that
supreme court ruling now when they go
back to mexico they are often in the
camps that we have seen uh for many
months now just on the other side in
tijuana the camps you're looking at
right now for instance
under the what were called the migrant
protection protocols now this is causing
some blowback from immigration advocacy
groups a whole slew of them have sent a
letter to the mexican president saying
that he should stand up to the biden
administration if they do reinstate the
remain in mexico policy the letter says
in part quote as a sovereign nation
mexico has the right to reject the
reinstatement of mpp or any future
iteration with this policy that aims to
externalize the us border into mexican
territory it is impossible to
re-implement mpp in a way that upholds
human rights and due process and mexico
has the responsibility to block this
detrimental policy now it's too early to
say of course as apprehensions continue
right along the mexico border this video
you're looking at now in laredo texas
it's too early to say whether if indeed
those migrant families are being
returned in greater numbers to mexico
whether that will have an effect in
perhaps dissuading some to try crossing
the border illegally would you to get
new figures for august at least dana
from customs and border protection
probably around the end of this week
that will give us the total for the
number of encounters in august remember
in july we had a record 212 000
anecdotally i would say that we might be
slightly below that but we're only in
one area of the border obviously we
can't see the bigger picture uh but it's
going to be very interesting to see what
those august figures are dana well it
didn't really slow down in the hot
summer months as it usually does so
we'll look forward to getting those
numbers jonathan thank you